vor der alten apotheke in hamburg können
die kunden seit 60 jahren bequem parken
dann rückt urplötzlich ein bautrupp im
auftrag der stadt an und baut diese
spargel vor die privaten parkplätze hier
kommt kein patient mehr auf die
apothekerin marita mosebach kann es
nicht glauben mag ich war völlig
schockiert ich wusste gar nicht was ich
sagen sollte in einer nacht und
nebelaktion riegelt das bezirksamt
wandsbek ende vergangenen jahres die
privaten parkplätze ab autos hätten den
bürgersteig beschädigt so die behörde
unglaublich nur weil ein paar alte
gehwegplatten kaputt sind dürfen die
kunden von frau mosebach nicht mehr vor
die apotheke fahren
das versteht kein mensch ist absoluter
schwachsinn also ich find s absoluten
schwachsinn 40 jahre bin ich hier
gefahren und immer ist alles gut
gegangen und 40
da macht es wenn man krank ist auf jeden
fall deutlich komplizierter als eine
absolute katastrophe
viele kunden lassen die apotheke fortan
links liegen die folge umsatzeinbußen
von bis zu 20 prozent
marita mosebach und ihre vermieterin
wenden sich an die stadt auf eigene
kosten senken sie den bürgersteig ab und
lassen für mehr als 3000 euro den belag
erneuern
trotzdem entriegelt die behörde dafür
lediglich einen parkplatz der rest
bleibt gesperrt
trotzdem nie ein unfall passiert ist
bestehen sie einfach weiter darauf und
sind nicht bereit diese sachen
zurückzunehmen und ich verstehe nicht
warum und ich hätte gerne eine erklärung
und weil sich die behörde nicht rührt
haben sie inzwischen klage gegen die
stadt eingereicht
auch für den länderspiegel gibt es keine
erklärung das bezirksamt wandsbek teilt
uns schriftlich mit aufgrund eines
laufenden gerichtsverfahrens werden wir
allerdings zurzeit keine inhaltliche
stellungnahme abgeben
dass die stadt einfach so private
parkplätze abriegelt dafür hat in
hamburg niemand verständnis
eigentlich ist es eine frechheit weil
das kommt ja eigentlich eine enteignung
gleich
weil wenn die apothekerin morgens sind
hierher kommen auf einmal solche bügel
und bestimmte plätze oder stellplätze
nicht mehr befahrbar sind von der straße
aus ohne dass vorher anzukündigen was
für ein hammer
ich find's einfach der spiegel ihr sinn
ist jetzt beim verwaltungsgericht
hamburg gelandet es muss entscheiden ob
die dinge bleiben oder doch weg kommen
dann könnten die kunden hier wieder ganz
normal parken wie es 60 jahre lang
völlig unproblematisch möglich war